okay um so today we will be discussing
how Greek culture spread around the
world and how it came to dominate uh the
Western World and became the basis of
Western
Civilization now normally um westerners
understood this process as one of
diffusion meaning that Greek
civilization was the best and so
everyone wanted um access to it okay so
it spread because Greek civilization was
the best uh historically that's not true
what happened was that what happened was
that Greek civilization spread through a
process of Conquest primarily uh by a
the great okay so the question I want to
um answer today is how did a the great
uh conquer the world because ex ex the
great himself is not Greek he's
Macedonian so he's he's like a close
cousin but he's not considered
culturally Greek he's from a place
called macedone okay which is in which
is north of Greece and for most of its
history macedone the kingdom of ma
Macedonia was poor it was weak it was
divided so how was it
possible that macedone the kingdom of
macedone would conquer the world and not
Sparta or Athens which for most most of
Greek history were the dominant Powers
okay so um for me to explain what
happened I need to explain to you two
thought experiments okay so we're going
to do two thought experiments to develop
the anal Tools in order to better
understand the process of military
conquest okay so let's do a thought
experiment there's a father and there's
a son
okay uh and they're both business people
they start a business the father starts
with nothing and he makes $10 million
okay which is a great
accomplishment the son takes his
business and expends it okay 10 million
and he turns $10 million The Inheritance
into 10
billion dollar okay and this happens a
lot
so who is the most more impressive of
the two the father or the son
the father is more impressive because he
started with nothing right it's much
harder to build something from nothing
than it is to expand something okay the
problem though is that we in society in
history in the media we celebrate the
sun because1 billion dollar is a lot of
money okay does that make sense so it's
a father who does all the work work and
builds the organization and the capacity
for growth it's a son who expands it and
gets all the credit okay and this
happens a lot in history now what we're
going to do is we're going to think
about the qualities of the father and a
son that allow them to succeed okay so
what can we say about the father how was
he able to build a great business he is
what
and the first thing we can say is he is
innovative right meaning he has a new
idea that allows him to capture markets
okay now it's possible that he stole the
idea um but that also shows that he has
wisdom and judgment right so he's
Innovative or he's W or he has wisdom
and
judgment okay doesn't make sense that's
a first major
quality of the father he's very
Innovative okay or he's wise and has has
good
judgment second um good qu second
quality about the father we can say is
that he's a very effective manager of
people
okay because remember he has nothing so
he has to build
loyalty among his workers he has to find
workers he has to recruit workers and he
has to make them work hard for it him
right so what can he do to find good
workers and ensure they work hard for
him and build the
business why would you want to go work
for someone and work hard for
him uh well they don't have they pay you
good money but a lot of people pay you
good money what's different about this
business good okay so um the vision
right or the dream so the business has a
vision and a dream that compels you okay
you see the potential for growth okay so
not only is the father Innovative but
he's also a Visionary he's a dreamer and
that's what attracts you to him okay the
other thing is that he's
Fair meaning that he promotes
Talent right you want to work for
someone who treat you fearly who will be
honest with you so if you work hard
he'll tell you wow you're working really
hard thank you so much okay but if
you're not working so hard then he might
give you some feedback on how to
improve okay and that's very hard to do
because normally what do we humans want
to do we so a good boss would promote
talent and most people would do
what promote his or her friends right
promote people that they like promote
people who suck up to them okay that's
the natural human um Instinct so in
other
words the father he's almost like
selfless okay he's always thinking about
the greater good which is really the
company or the business right so he's
going to work harder than everyone else
if you come to work at 7 o'clock in the
morning he'll come at he'll come in at
6:00 if you leave at 10:00 at night
he'll he'll leave at midnight okay he's
always working harder than than you to
show that he is the most loyal to the
company and that's what makes you loyal
to the company as well okay does that
make sense so these are the three
distinct
qualities of a good business person okay
a good founder Innovative a good manag
of people by sharing The Vision by
communicating the vision and by being
fair to People by
promoting um Talent okay and also
selfless um very disciplined
okay we'll work we'll work very hard in
order to achieve the greater good to
ensure the company succeeds now it turns
out this that these personality traits
are consistent with extremely successful
people okay so when we study um other
great leaders for example gangas Khan
Muhammad then we will recognize they all
share very similar person traits and I
want you to remember the three distinct
qualities that make them great world
leaders okay the first
is they
are um
strategic to the point of
visionary this means they have a vision
of what the world should be and then
they have a long-term plan on how to
achieve that okay they're very strategic
the second thing is they are
Innovative to a point of
revolutionary okay so what they
understand is if you want to change the
world You Must Destroy the status quo
you must change the way Society is
structured okay and they're willing to
do that even though they know it'll be a
very bloody process involving lots of
Wars okay that's a second qual that they
have that's different from every else
the third quality is they are extremely
disciplined to the point of
selfless okay they they are
fanatical and obsessed with achieving
their Vision they won't eat they won't
sleep until they achieve their vision
for them it's all about achieving the
vision and the greater good as opposed
to uh personal happiness right does that
make sense so um this is a pattern that
we'll see over and over again where the
great world leaders that have changed
history forever have possessed these
three distinct qualities that make them
unique of their time okay and so um G as
Khan Muhammad are two examples but also
like napan and Julius Caesar okay
basically all the great world conquerors
um in human history have these similar
characteristics okay does that make
sense now the sun is very
different okay so if a father succeeds
because he is innovative why does a son
succeed no he's not actually how do you
transform $10 million into10 billion if
you're a business person what what what
must you do
you must be aggressive right you're
aggressive risk
taker the father is not a risk taker
because he has no opportunities to take
risks okay so the example here is you
have $10 million you can go the the bank
and say I have a great business can you
lend me a billion dollars so I can buy
out my competitors okay now when you do
that that's risky but that's how you
expand very quickly right so the first
thing about the son that's very
different from the father is is he
succeeds by taking risk that no one else
are willing to take okay that's the
first thing who does he
promote his father promotes Talent who
does he
promote who does he want around
him exactly he wants his friends okay so
he's going to
promote
loyalty all right if you listen to him
if you obedient to him if he likes you
then he will promote you okay the
father's very different the father will
not do that because if you do that
that's going to hurt the internal
structure of your company
right and the father is
selfless what does a son care
about what drives
him what does he really care about what
so the the father is motivated to build
a great company right he wants to
achieve his vision what drives the
son usually it's the idea of personal
Glory
okay he's very
selfish you understand he wants to be
remembered he wants to be
famous he wants to be admired and
respected okay the father cares about
the vision the son cares about the
personal Glory why would the son put
personal Glory first and first
think about his
psychology what drives him what does he
want to
prove exactly exactly you understand
he's greater than his father it's
insecurity
because everyone will say to him you are
where you are because your father built
a great organization so for him he must
prove he's better than the father by
expanding and by winning glory for
himself okay does that make sense and
again we will see this pattern in human
history all the time and we will you I
want you to remember this because this
describes perfectly the relationship
between Phillip the second of Macedon
okay the man who actually built the
greatest military in the world and
action of the great who will take this
Army the greatest army in the world and
Conquer
Persia okay does that make sense all
right so over the next two classes I
will show
you Philip how this relationship between
the Father and Son describes very well
the personalities of Philip and
Alexander
okay all right does that make
sense okay so and this repeats itself
throughout history this makes sense to
you right you will see this in life you
will see this throughout history
okay now the other thing I want us to
look at another thought thought
experiment
is throughout history what we discovered
is poor countries
often conquer rich
countries and for us that's very
confusing because normally we think if
you are rich you have a very strong
military you have advanced technology
and you have a lot of resources right
and therefore it's very hard to be
conquered but we see this Crow history
all the time where poor Nations poor
countries quickly conquered Rich Nations
okay so how can we explain this and to
explain this we'll do another thought
experiment okay so let's compare North
Korea with South
Korea okay and these countries are same
culture right same people but they are
night and day North Korea we know is
poor South Korea is Rich North Korea is
primitive meaning they are not they
don't have that much Advent technology
um South Korea is very Advanced right
technologically advanced right think of
Samsung the phones the cars and the
phones they produce uh and and the
computers they produce right a very
Advanced country the last thing is that
North Korea is a dictatorship
uh and South Korea's
democracy so if we were to take a
snapshot of North and South Korea today
right then then we could easily predict
that in 20 years time North Korea would
be poorer South Korea would be richer
right okay but that may not happen what
is self C's
problem what is self Korea's biggest
problem do you do you know
it's not having
children in fact it has the world's
lowest F trility rate at 0.8 okay it's
women are refused to have
children and not only that but South
Korean culture is becoming more and more
anti family they hate kids there are
lots of restaurants lots of um uh places
that refuse to let kids in okay so this
is a very weird state of State of
Affairs right what's driving the low
parate do you think usually why are why
are young women refusing to have
children
because yeah right inequality
right if you feel that if you're just a
normal person the rich have all the
resources it's very hard for you to
advance so I have children okay
now North Korea doesn't have this
problem right because it's poor
therefore it has
equality and because it has equality
people there are united right they're
not divide they're United and what
else they're obedient right they listen
to what the government tells them to do
and last thing is they're
hungry they will work very hard for very
little okay you understand
so it is possible that in 20 years time
North Korea overtakes South Korea
because its people are willing to work
harder than the South Korean people okay
doesn't make sense so
um evidence for this is that right now
North Korea is sending weapons and
soldiers to the war in
Ukraine doesn't make sense so when you
do that you make a lot of money for
yourself right and so with this money
you can upgrade your military and then
what you can do is threaten South Korea
okay North Korea can say to South Korea
our military is not stronger than your
military and what will self create do do
in
response you
think North Korea is like we're going to
come and invade you what will South
Korea do in response
someone wants to attack you right so how
do you get this person not to attack
you exactly do you understand all right
give them money so North Korea doesn't
even have to attack South Korea North
Korea just has to threaten to attack
South Korea and South Korea will give
them a lot of money not to attack do you
understand and by doing that right North
becomes richer and more military
Advanced South South Kore just becomes
poorer do you understand and because
North Korea the Army is fighting in
other places like Ukraine it's
developing all this experience and
expertise that will allow it to
eventually overwhelm South Korea does it
make sense so in this thought
experiment it's possible that North
Korea can eventually conquer South Korea
okay doesn't make sense and this gives
us
an understanding of why Macedonia
Macedon was able to conquer all of
Greece even though Mason was by far one
of the poorest
places in Greece at that time okay does
that make sense because the people are
hungry United and
obedient all
right any questions so
far about this okay so I want you to
remember these two thought experiments
because they will help us explain a lot
of history and I would refer to these
two thought experiments some more as we
go along in the course okay all right
but but does this make sense to you so
far great all right so now let's focus
specifically on Philip II of Macedon how
was he able to conquer all of gree given
that his Nation Macedon was poor weak
and divided okay
all right so King Phillip okay he was
born in
383 BCE okay and I want to talk about
the
world of Greece and Macedon at this at
the time of his
birth okay so around this time there are
three major powers in Greece okay a
there's
Athens remember that even though Athens
lost the pelian war um it's still very
wealthy and it still has the best Navy
in all of Greece okay so it's still a
major power then you have um Sparta
which for most of Greek history was
considered the best military right and
then you have sorry
um let me try
to use another
okay so the map okay so this is Sparta
here to the South this is
Athens and then to the north it's a
place called thieves and what's
interesting is at this time thieves has
become the most dominant military in
Greece primarily because Sparta and
Athens decimated um each other during
the palan war okay so because of the war
thieves has uh um became became the
dominant power in Greece at this time
okay and then to the far north is
Macedon okay the kingdom of
Macedon now Macedon is very poor weak
and divided so let me explain why it is
first of all it has a geography problem
it the nation is divided between um
agricultural Farmland to the South and
mountains to the north okay
so most of its land can't even grow
crops and where it can grow crops its
farmers are just peasants okay now the
problem is that there are lots of tribes
in the mountains and the way they make
their living usually is by coming and
raiding your farmland and there's
nothing that you can do about it because
if you go chase them they go back to the
mountains okay so that's the first
problem the economy uh is very very
divided and it's very and um the people
don't have that many resources okay
that's the first problem second problem
is Macedon is completely surrounded by
hostile
Powers okay so you have the kingdom of
phas over here and that's a long-term
enemy then you havea over here okay and
these are warlike mountainous people who
live in fortresses it's almost
impossible to invade them and it's easy
for them to come and attack you okay so
they're a huge problem to the South is a
place called
FIS and they have one of the best
militaries in um Greece okay they're
known for their Cavalry their
Horsemen and then of course you also
have thieves Athens and Sparta which
also want to play a role in controlling
Mason
okay and over here of course across the
sea is called Persia
and for um some history maedon was
actually a province of of Persia okay
Persia actually conquered or subjugated
Macedon so Macedon is always being
threatened by a more uh Superior power
and it it keeps on losing these wars
Okay the third problem it has is that um
it it's a kingdom has a king and the
kingom and the King has many many wives
and why would this be a problem
exactly okay they're a lot of sons and
they fight over who will be king and the
thing is
that these sons are always supported by
another foreign power okay because the
foreign powers want Macedon to be uh
Always In
conflict okay so for most of its history
maedon was poor weak and divided
and then philli II changes all that so
he's born in
383 and then in from 369 to 365 for
about five years he's a hostage in
thieves the reason why is maedon lost a
war to thieves and to ensure that madon
does not rebel against thieves madon had
to send
hostages and so Philip was a hostage in
thieves but he's a prince so he shooted
very very very
nicely in um thieves and he can do what
whatever he wants the thing that he
wants to do is he wants to understand
why thieves is a dominant military power
in Greece at this time and he learns
from the best them generals they become
his they they become his
mentors okay so what makes thieves so
effective is the idea of the Sacred Band
of Thieves
this is the secret to the power of
Thieves okay these are
300 soldiers who spend every day
training to be the best soldiers they
they can and
um in many ways they're like Special
Forces okay and this is modeled of
Sparta right the difference is this the
difference is in Sparta only citizens
only Aristocrats can be
soldiers but in thieves these 300 people
were volunteers they were commoners who
wanted to be
soldiers and so the first thing Philip
learned in thieves is anyone can be a
soldier not just the rich okay with
proper
training anyone can learn to be a great
Soldier that's the first thing he
learned second thing he learned is when
you have Elite group of soldiers it's
really about how to use them effectively
okay so the traditional Warfare in
Greece at this time it's called a PHX
right the
hoplight PHX okay so remember it is like
a moving wall they move together slowly
and try to crush the enemy
okay The Innovation the thians did was
say we're going to do a slant Okay the
reason why is when you do a slant you
can put the 300 sacred ban first against
the best soldiers of the enemy okay and
we know that in a fair fight these 300
will always destroy the first soldiers
of the enemy when you do that there's a
massive psychological effect
right and so what happens is the phic
breaks breaks formation and the F breaks
formation and people start running away
They're All Dead okay so that that is
the
major
innovation of Thieves at this time okay
and from the the best generals of
Thieves okay Philip understood the
importance of
discipline in an
army and this is new okay because in
Greece remember uh the spars had
discipline but most armies like the
Athenians they were citizen soldiers
they did this for fun they did this they
did this as a civic duty they did this
part-time okay so they they would be
training when they weren
fighting now when you train you deop
discipline with discipline you have
three major strengths okay the first
major strength that you have is the idea
of
Mobility speed and what this means is
your army can March March much faster
than other
armies okay so maybe this is important
because um maybe you want to attack a
city right if you get there really fast
and you're able to Siege a city and
destroy it the city cannot ask for
reinforcements okay because
reinforcements will come too slowly does
that make sense okay so this is a major
Innovation the idea of Mobility okay
second is the idea of
coordination coordination so different
military units are able to work together
and this is really important so um in
Greece at this time there are maybe two
different land forces right there's a
phenx and then there's a Cavalry and
they do the own thing okay but with
discipline you can actually get them to
work together and if you get them to
work together you create something call
the Anvil and Hammer strategy okay Anvil
and Hammer
okay so the idea of an anvil is you put
something in place okay and the hammer
is you just knock that thing apart okay
so in this attack the Cavalry becomes
the hammer the Anvil is a phallic so
with discipline the falling is able to
lock the other enemy Army in place okay
and then what happens is the Cavalry
sees this and they stream in from the
back and destroy the enemy does it make
sense it's called The Anvil and Hammer
strategy and uh the theevans used it but
Phil started to use it as well and you
can use this with discipline okay if
every Soldier knows his or her role in
the
Army and with this with coordination you
can also have the idea of
flexibility okay so remember the Greeks
thought using the h f and that's it but
what Philip understood is hey if I have
horation I can change my strategy and
tactics according to the enemy right so
he had different units he had archers he
had shieldbearers okay people whose job
was to hold Shields he had fallings and
he had Cavalry and ACC and in response
to different enemies he would change his
strategy using these different units
okay does that make sense and so as over
time um this Army if you have these
three things Mobility coordination and
flexibility you'll be Invincible no one
can beat you okay because the very idea
that an army could do this at that time
was unheard
of okay does that make sense right so
that's that's what he learned in thieves
it is possible for you to transform your
Army in a way that makes it highly
disciplined and once you have discipline
it will become
invincible okay so he became resolved to
take all this education and transform
the Macedonian
army okay he got his chance
in uh
359 Okay the reason why is um his
brother died and his and the brother's
son his nephew was too young so he
became region okay he became um the sort
of
um uh placeholder before the son can
become of age okay but once you became
region he basically became de facto King
for his entire life and as region he was
determined to
transform the Macedonian military and at
this time the M Macedonian military was
getting destroyed by everyone okay ayia
attacked and destroyed the Army th
attacked and destroyed the Army okay the
m m Army was a complete joke and he
became determined to transform it and
what he recognized is if I want
transform the milit the the Army I need
to turn it into a
meritocracy
okay
meritocracy so traditionally um because
uh in Macedon you have a nobility it's
always the you like all decision
decision are made by social status
okay so a person Rises according to his
social status as opposed to his
Merit and Philip um was determined to
change
that and the the thing that he did that
was extremely controversial was he made
the caly which was full nobility equal
to the
Infantry which was made of commoners
peasants okay so in this new system as
long as you perform well in battle
you'll be promoted okay and one of the
people he promoted very heavily and who
would become um his most successful
General his name is p par Monon
parmenion okay I I want you to remember
this guy parmenion okay because he would
basically become Philip's
partner in war and his greatest General
even though ponan he was not he was born
into the Lord nobility okay he certainly
had so manyy but but Philip treated him
as a
partner and he allowed P pan to lead
armies on his own he was not afraid that
permanon would Rebel okay he trusted p
parmenion so Phil was a
tremendous um tremendous um he he had
tremendous understanding and Judgment of
people he he knew who to trust and he
knew how to use people
effectively the other thing that he did
that was very important was he needed to
make the Army loyal to him and what he
understood is if you want the Army loyal
to you you need to do do three things
okay the first thing is you need to
fight with
them you understand he was not in the
back watching the battle he was in the
front leading the battle he was training
with them every day he trained harder
than everyone else in fact in one battle
Philip lost lost an the eye and he had
many battle wounds and scarves okay and
so because of that his soldiers were
fanatically loyal to him okay and also
because Philip was fighting with his
soldiers every day he did not want to
risk the lives of his soldiers you
understand he was very strategic he
would not put his soldiers In Harm's Way
and so his soldiers became even more
loyal to
him second thing that he did was he ate
and drank with them okay these common
soldiers he would spend his time just
eating and drinking with them and that
told the soldiers
hey we're equals we're friends and I'm
willing to listen to your
complaints okay here's your opportunity
to complain a commander here's here's an
opportunity to complain about me I'm
willing to listen to
you okay does that make sense the third
thing was he was an accent Communicator
he would give speeches explaining his
vision right he wanted to make
Macedonian Macedon great he wanted
Macedon to conquer of Greece and then
conquer Persia he wanted glory for his
country okay but not only that but he
praised people like parmenion okay he
used his speeches to praise
soldiers that were good
examples and obviously that made penan
feel really good right that made him
even more loyal to
Phillip
okay so Phillip over time was able to
build a strong loyal unified discipline
Army using these
strategies
okay so um the other thing that Philip
did was he started to while he was
starting to build his army his enemies
were still attacking him right and what
he did that was
counterintuitive was he basically
negotiated you understand he used
diplomacy
he understood
that having the best
military is just a um so sorry Sor let
me rephrase this having smart diplomacy
is just as good as having the world's
best military right does that make sense
because remember in at this time it's
basically Game of Thrones every nation
is at each other throat okay and they
hate each other okay so Sparta hates the
thieves thieves hates hates Athens they
really didn't get along okay so what
Phil could do was use diplomacy to build
alliances against other enemies okay so
so he was using diplomacy a lot in order
to buy time for him to train up his
army okay he would also
marry um uh the princesses of other
nations okay as part of his diplomacy so
Philip was known as a great strategist
but much more importantly he was known
also as a br Diplomat someone who knew
how to
negotiate uh and deceive his
enemies okay so um after he started to
build his army he started to make his
move okay the first thing he did was he
basically secured his Northern Frontier
he got into these wars with his enemies
to the north and he secured his Northern
Frontier that's important okay because
he wants to move into the South
eventually but he needs to make sure
that he's not attacked from behind Okay
so that's the first thing he does second
second that he second thing that he does
is in
347 he invades a city called amphipolis
and he conquers it this is important
because amphibolis has gold
mines okay now he has resource he has
money and with these resources he can
pay his soldiers right because his
soldiers are training every day they're
not farming he's they're training every
day so he he can now pay them he can now
buy the Loyalty of the
nobility and he can um stir national
settlement in Macedon by building uh
projects by building roades okay he can
improve the economy okay and the last
thing that he does with the money is he
starts bribing everyone okay he
basically starts bribing the nobility of
Athens um other nations to support him
okay so he's being very strategic and
very
clever um in 356 his son in here a the
Great Is Born to his wife Olympia okay
and the last major event is in 338 BCE
is the Battle of Tonia Tania this is the
last battle
between um Philip and the people who
opposed him so in Tania the two Nations
that that oppos him are thieves and
Athens
but at this time the problem is the
great generals of Thieves have all died
okay and Athens um they basically
brought their were stalkers to support
him so Athens didn't really put out a
great Army and in this battle of Sheria
Phil the second with his like modern
highly disciplined loyal Army destroyed
everyone okay he crushed thieves he
crushed Athens
and um he United all of Greece so he
destroyed all the entire Army of Athens
and he almost destroyed thieves but what
happened was it when it was clear that
thieves was about to lose the battle the
sacred Band of Thieves
okay stood in the way okay they
basically sacrificed themselves so the
other Army the other soldiers of th
could
Escape
okay and so the SEC B thieves was
forever destroyed the irony of course is
U it's a sacred Ben of Thieves that
taught Philip how to build a great
Army okay and his in his last act he
destroyed the sacred ban of Thieves and
now he unite all of Greece now that he
unite all of Greece his ambition now is
to take his army and Conquer Persia okay
so what he did was he sent his great
General parmenion
into um Persia okay remember in Anatolia
at this time which is today turkey there
are lots of Greek colonies that are
under Persian Rule and for the longest
time they want to be free of Persian
rule okay so ponan went over with a
Vanguard about 10,000 men to set to
begin The Invasion okay
okay and Philip was about to go
over and Lead Invasion but his daughter
was about to get married okay so he had
to attend the
wedding at the
wedding
um he had one
bodyguard because um at the wedding
there'll be lot lots of quick diplomats
right so he wanted to appear
approachable so he didn't have his
entire bodyguard in place he had one
bodyguard okay his bodyguard took his
sword and stabbed him in the rib killing
him then his bodyguard was killed by by
the other bodyguard
so Phil was assassinated before he could
launch his invasion of
Persia okay and when he died um it was
like 337
okay okay so Philip was really in the
prime of his life he had like 30 40
Years of military conquest to
go okay he died very young and his son
Alexander um who was like 189 at this
time he now became
king it was Alexander who would lead his
army into Persia and C all Persia and
move all the way to India or or like the
um or Pakistan really
okay so for the longest time historians
do not know what happened how is it
possible for this great man Philip II to
be assassinated in the prim his life all
right now there are three
explanations there three major
explanations the first explanation is is
it was
Persia
Persia um knew that Philip was about to
invade and so they hired The Bodyguard
to kill him okay that's the first
explanation second explanation is it was
personal um the like so the story is
very complicated but apparently the
bodygard and Philip were lovers okay
they were homosexual lovers and then
Philip found someone else and the body
of God became very jealous and so it's a
very complicated story okay it was
personal
and then there's one more explanation
the other explanation
was it was the mother of alander
olympas and Alexander
okay right so these are the three
explanations so if you want to and like
honestly we'll never ever know what
happened okay but if you want to
evaluate a murder you always look at two
things look at opportunity
who have the who have the chance to kill
him you get
multip okay do you understand so if you
look at these two things let's evaluate
all three possibilities Persia okay it
had the motive but it didn't have the
opportunity you understand how could it
access Philip's inner court right and
Philip's not a dumb guy you would know
exactly who to trust and who not to
trust and usually if Persia was afraid
of philli what what they could do was
basically give Sparta and Athens all the
money to
attack uh Philip right so I don't think
it's Persia I think most people agree it
it was not Persia okay second
possibility is it was
personal and that's kind of strange
right because Phillip he's very good and
inspiring loyalty from others he's also
good at reading people right so
um I don't think it was personal I mean
it could be but I don't think it is okay
and this leaves us a possibility of
olympas and
Alexander and here it makes sense
because they both have both the motive
and the opportunity okay so let me first
explain motive the motive is very easy
okay to
understand if Philip were to die
Alexander would become king right and
this is at the height
of the glory of Macedon they have the
world's greatest military they conquered
all of Greece Persia is an easy target
okay and maybe they were afraid that if
Philip goes to Persia it'll be too
late the other problem is Phil philli is
an excellent judge of character and
what's clear about Alexander very from a
very early age is he was a very violent
young man he couldn't really control his
emotions you're philli right you're kind
of like do I really want this guy to be
the he to my Empire could he managed the
Empire plus remember Philip has a lot of
wives right so over time he could have
new
Sons okay does that make sense so the
motive is very clear and the opportunity
makes sense because they're all one
family right The Bodyguard is in
constant communication with olympas okay
and what gives evidence
what what what provides evidence for
this line of thinking is after the death
of Phil body guard named uh
penus Olympus actually made a monument
to
him
okay and next class we when we look at
the life of Alexander we will see a lot
of evidence that suggest he wanted his
father dead okay maybe he didn't
participate
in the killing of his father in the
plotting
um um of the assassination but he
clearly won his father
dead okay and next class we will discuss
this all right
so uh doesn't make sense to you okay and
again um what what we what we will
understand is this pattern of a great
man emerging who creates a revolution
that transforms the world it will repeat
itself in this way many times including
with Muhammad and with gang Khan with
Napoleon with Julius Caesar okay but
they all have this sort of similar
personality and they're all working
within a similar social
context
okay does that make sense any questions
so far about
this
like that's right hostage that's
right that's a great question okay so
the
question why did they treat Philip so
well and why did he give them so much
knowledge and the answer is first of all
no one thinks madone will ever be a
threat do you understand no one takes
Mason seriously it's like today no one
would take self North Korea seriously
right you understand everyone thinks in
East Asia the major powers are China and
Japan and everyone thinks North Korea is
a complete joke okay this place will
collapse in five years time so no one
during this time ever thought Macedon
could ever
challenge uh Sparta or Athens or thieves
okay no one did okay so it was just
overconfidence second thing is um um if
you're the thebans you want you want
your enemies are Sparta in Athens okay
so you want to build allies the best way
to build allies is by building strong
relationships with weaker Nations who
then rely on you right and the best way
to do that is by
indoctrinating uh the Future Leaders of
that Nation right like philli so
basically they want to treat him nice so
Philip would be
thankful to thieves they didn't re they
didn't realize Philip had other
intentions okay and and and it's
impossible because Phillip is one of
these individuals these men who who we
call Great men of history they stand
outside of History they are in many ways
not human okay they don't behave normal
humans behave right normally if you're a
prince you just want to have a good time
right you just want to enjoy your weal
you want to promote your friends right
and you want personal Glory but Philip
wanted to change CH the world and so you
can't possibly predict that right okay
does that make sense all
right okay great question though okay
any more
questions oh great great question okay
the Alex all right okay so philli not
only learn military strategy
uh from thieves but he he was also a
military
innovator okay so um he made a lot of
changes to the phic so the phic um it's
very strong but there are a lot of
issues with it okay the first major
issue with it is it's not very mobile
because everyone's carrying heavy armor
so the first thing that Philip did was
he made um he he he lightened the load
okay so he had his he had his um
soldiers wear less Army then the
question then is well if you wear less
armor then how do you protect yourself
and the answer is two things okay he did
the first thing he did was he made the
spear very long it was a it became a
pike okay so it became very hard to
reach the fallings because the spear was
in the way okay the pike was in the way
and the other thing that he did was he
added a
new um uh unit called Shield
bearers okay so the shear bearers were
on the flanks on the sides to to protect
the fallings okay so that's how he
improved the fallings and so when the
Macedonian fallings came into contact
with the Greek fallings the Macedonian
fallings proved Superior because of
these invasions okay remember they were
lighter they could move around faster
and they had longer Spears okay so they
could maintain distance from you a lot
longer and also they had these Shield
bearers who were mobile and could adapt
to situations okay so if one part of the
F was being threatened then the sh
bearers could Converge on that and like
basically lick the
down does that make sense right so what
made Philip so um such a genius was he
was very flexible okay he was all he was
always looking at what happened at
battles and making adjustments in order
to become stronger that's that and
that's why his soldiers were so loyal to
him because he was such a great General
and he put the lives of of his men first
and for okay and what we will discover
next class is Alexander is the complete
opposite he's always risking the lives
of his
men does that make sense okay any more
questions but that's a great question
yeah sorry so I I obviously don't have
enough time to go into all the details
okay there's a lot of changes okay but
the Finks um is a major innovation
right you have the shield bearers in
place excuse
me above you okay well they have helmets
and they have shields as
well okay do you
understand that's right yeah so the
shield bearers were really the um secret
sauce of the um Macedon Army okay
because the shield bearers Were Meant to
resolve any issues that that might arise
in
battle Yeah but but yeah so do you
understand how how how this works okay
again but you have the flexibility
because these are extremely disciplined
and loyal men okay and what we will
discover is when we get to Alexander is
even though Alexander was bold and
aggressive he he wouldn't make mistakes
but the loyalty and discipline of the
mstone army would compensate for a lot
of his strategic mistakes okay does that
make
sense great any more
questions okay so was this interesting
for you okay and this is clear right
okay because again the thing about this
class it's different is we build on all
this knowledge okay we will see how um
um military strategy changes over time
and we'll see how um the Greeks um the
the macons will influence uh Greek
culture okay all right so next class we
will do alander the Great